this video is made possible by - lane -
Lane is a one-stop shop digital identity
protection tool who go beyond just being
an amazing password manager and provide
identity protection monitoring a
restoration and more visit - Lane comm
forward slash biographic Sand apply the
promo code biographic s' for a 10%
discount the Pentagon Papers the Iraq
war logs US history
it's full of infamous leaks that blew
the government wide open but there's one
set of leaks that stands head and
shoulders above the others in 2013 a
contractor with the National Security
Agency or NSA quietly handed a cache of
documents to the Guardian these details
how the NSA had been hoovering up
information on millions of Americans
while lying to Congress it was the
single most explosive story of the post
9/11 era and the man behind it all
well that was Edward Snowden a young
computer whiz from North Carolina
Snowden is today infamous currently he's
holed up in asylum in Russia he's both
loved and loathed by millions to some
he's a fearless whistleblower who
sacrificed everything to do what was
right to others
he's the 21st century version of a cold
war defector but the truth it's more
complex than either of those portrayals
Snowden's life is one of contradictions
of surprises and enough shades of grey
to fill a million l james novels today
we investigate the man behind the most
notorious leak in american history if
you know the name Elizabeth City North
Carolina it's likely because of the
coast guard base by some measures the
busiest in the United States the base
dominates the lives of local residents
the Snowden's they were no exception
when Edward Joseph Snowden was born on
June the 21st 1983 it was into a family
with deep military connections young
Snowden's maternal grandfather Edward J
Barrett was a Rear Admiral and his
father Lonnie also worked in the Coast
Guard for Snowden
memens our childhood instilled with deep
respect for the services but it was also
a childhood marked by something more
tragic the slow breakdown of
parents's marriage Lonnie and Elizabeth
Snowden known to her friends as Wendy
were high school sweethearts soon
married young
although Wendy suffer from epilepsy it
wasn't debilitating she managed to get a
job as a Maryland district court clerk
moving the family north in 1992 but if
the snowden's were expecting their new
lives in Maryland to be easy while they
were mistaken as Wendy and Long's
marriage drifted young Snowden was
stumbling into a crisis at high school
despite being clearly intelligent the
teenage boy he didn't really Excel up
anything when he missed four months
study after capturing glandular fever in
1998 it knocked him back to a place that
he couldn't recover from he flunked out
of high school
perhaps desperate up self something from
this debacle Snowden enrolled in
computer classes at Anne Arundel
Community College but his prospects they
were pretty low message board posts he
left around this time tinged with
cheerful desperation about being
unemployed the family stumbled on for
another couple of years but by 2001 the
writing was on the wall Wendy and lon
split and Wendy took off Ellicott City
near Baltimore one year later 19 year
old Snowden he followed her at this
stage Edward Snowden was about as far
from a potential biographic subjects as
you're likely to get his only
achievement was being webmaster of an
anime message board yet even now there
were two clues as to his future
notoriety the first was his incomparable
tech skills after enrolling at an or
until Snowden had discovered that he had
not just an aptitude for computers but a
genius Ellicott City is home to
somewhere that's going to become very
important to our story it's home to the
NSA's headquarters unfortunately their
real life isn't as narratively pleasing
as fiction and we'll need to take a
quick detour in order to get there on
March the 20th 2003 the u.s. invaded
Iraq although the main fighting was over
by the end of May a call for new
recruits went out nationwide this call
struck a chord with the unemployed
Snowden maybe it was his family's Coast
Guard backgrounds but for whatever
reason Snowden felt compelled to join up
in May 2004 he reported for duty at Fort
Benning Georgia his training it didn't
last long
Snowden later claims that he broke both
legs but the army claims he flunked out
with shins blitz
either way the result was the same after
barely a month Snowden was dis
charged he returned to Maryland's again
and unemployed failure finally in 2005
Snowden got a security guard job at
Maryland's Center for Advanced Study of
language and it was really here that our
story could have ended except for one
little fact that Center it was backed by
the NSA and the NSA were desperate to
recruit computer geeks after the Soviet
Union fell way back in 1991 America's
intelligence agencies they went through
an era of downsizing and shedding of
staff that all changed on September the
11th 2001 faced with the new threat of
terrorism the agencies were desperate to
make up for lost time
they were also desperate to catch up
with evolving tech way into the 2000s
the senior staff was so technologically
illiterate that it would be a challenge
for them to distinguish the difference
between a laptop and a sandwich and with
that it was clearly time to start hiring
our best tech guys and one of the best
just happened to be working as an NSA
security guard within months Snowden had
switched his security job for IT he must
have made an impression because not two
years after flunking out of basic
military training in mid 2006 young
Snowden got a job offer from the CIA
saying yes to that offer would turn out
to be a key decision in his life the
young IT genius was whisked away to
Geneva in Switzerland in 2007 while his
job was a mixture of cool and not so
cool from maintaining network security
to just fixing the aircon the money at
paid was certainly no joke as a CIA
technician Snowden was able to live
every boys James Bond fantasies he
bought a brand new BMW befriended an
Estonian rockstar and played the stock
market boasting that had lost $20,000 in
a single month he also traveled
extensively washing up in Rome Bosnia
and in London not that his opinions of
these places were always PC of London's
vibrant Muslim community he wrote they
were terrifying I didn't want to get out
of the car yet even in this dream job
disillusionment could creep in
in 2008 Snowden supposedly witnessed the
CIA arranging for a banker to be caught
drunk driving and then offering to
suppress the charge in return for
cooperation the Swiss authorities
they've denied this ever happened still
the
wish that Snowden felt working for the
CIA it was certainly real he would later
claim much of what I saw in Geneva
really disillusioned me about how my
government functions I realized that I
was a part of something that was doing
far more harm than good
not that he seems like a potential
whistleblower just yet when the New York
Times published a leaked Pentagon plan
to attack Iran in 2009 Snowden raged
online that anyone who leaked such
information to the press should be shot
in the balls still there was no doubt
that Snowden was struggling with
something in Geneva it was making him
angry in February of 2009 he abruptly
resigned from the CIA later sources in
the agency said that had been on the
verge of being fired for trying to hack
into their database back in the United
States the young computer whiz he
underwent to change his message board
posts the game full of angry rants
against government programs like social
welfares invective against obama's new
administration in a world full of angry
young men it seemed Edward Snowden was
simply another voice screaming into the
void
but there was one crucial difference
here Snowden was still useful within a
couple of months of leaving the CIA
Snowden had a new job this time as a
contractor for Dell working on NSA
projects the first was working on anti
cyber spying software in Tokyo for a
lifelong anime fan moving to Japan
should have been a dream come true but
instead at lunch Snowden into a moral
nightmare
[Music]
on April the 5th 2010 WikiLeaks is
Julian Assange previewed a leaked
military video at a National Press Club
events known as collateral murder
it showed US military pilots gunning
down two Reuters journalists mistaken
for terrorists in Baghdad in 2007 the
video was the first major scoop in the
history of WikiLeaks it was also the
beginning of the biggest intelligence
leak in history throughout the rest of
the year
WikiLeaks The Guardian the New York
Times and Der Spiegel published the
Afghan war logs the Iraq war logs and
finally a trove of US diplomatic cables
that were leaked supplied to WikiLeaks
by intelligence analyst Chelsea Manning
the classified files turned the world's
opinion of the United States upside down
but not Edward Snowden's over in Japan
the young IT professional had become
increasingly disturbed by the work the
NSA was up to On February the 18th 2010
he posted on a message board it really
concerns me how little this sort of
corporate behavior bothers those outside
of technology circles society really
seems to have developed an unquestioning
obedience towards spooky types
it wasn't until Manning's leaks shook
the media that Snowden seems to have
decided to reveal the NSA's secrets in
2011 Dell transferred him back to
Maryland from Japan on the outside this
was perfect for Snowden he moved in with
his younger girlfriends the
free-spirited Lindsay Mill's inside
Snowden had made a decision
it was while back in Maryland that he
started downloading the documents that
he would soon release to the entire
world in 2012 Snowden contacted the Tor
project an online community dedicated to
providing everyone with the tools needed
to encrypt their internet activity while
this seems innocuous enough to all was
deeply connected with WikiLeaks many
have suggested that Snowden made contact
with tor as a way of getting to Asajj if
that was the plan though it soon ran
into trouble with a capital T on June
the 19th 2012 the WikiLeaks founder fled
to the Ecuadorian Embassy in London to
avoid an arrest on a rape charge the
subsequent media circus may have made
Snowden rethink WikiLeaks is the place
to publish his revelations by now
Snowden and Mills they were in Hawaii
where Snowden had to work on the NSA's
regional cryptological
Center at this point he was actively
looking for opportunities to steal
documents but he may have also been
looking for something else validation
for his genius that summer snowed in the
hack - the answers for an NSA job
promotion test and subsequently aced it
when he was offered a new position he
got angry that it wasn't high enough up
and he rejected it
the NSA's Deputy Director would later
tell reporters that he considers this
the moment when Snowden turned on the
agency whatever the truth it wasn't only
at work that people were noticing the
change in Snowden in July 2012 Lindsey
Mill's blogged that the couple's
relationship in Hawaii was under stress
by October she was writing about heavy
conversations and stress paralysis
whatever was preying on Snowden's mind
it was certainly tormenting them both
that Thanksgiving bills returned to the
US mainland to see her family for an
extended break while he was away
Snowden finally set the wheels of his
plan in motion on December the 1st 2012
Guardian columnist and vocal WikiLeaks
defender Glenn Greenwald got a rather
unusual email this email suggested that
he set up a PGP encryption software on
his laptop like anyone getting such a
paranoid email Greenwald ignored it
assuming the sender was a crank
little did Greenwald know that this was
his first contact with a man who would
soon make his career a month after being
frozen out by Greenwald Snowden tried
again this time he contacted the
journalists friends documentary maker
Laura Poitras a Poitras was deeply
connected to the Tor project that we
mentioned earlier when she first heard
from Snowden she assumed that he was
trying to entrap her but when her
contacts at or gave Snowden the green
light she began to listen using a fake
name Snowden told Poitras that he was a
high-ranking intelligence officer this
was a total lie but the next part it
wasn't he told her that he could get a
hold of files that would paint the u.s.
in a very bad light if Poitras wanted to
see them all she had to do was get
Greenwald on board that February Snowden
changed jobs again while still working
at the NSA Hawaii Center he took a pay
card to move from contracting with Dell
to Booz Allen Hamilton his new role was
a sysadmin a role with - unbelievable
bonuses for the potential leaker one it
made Snowden one of the only people at
the NSA
a legitimate reason to carry normally
forbidden thumb drives and to it gave
them access to almost the entire system
still some to this day a skeptical that
even assist admin could have accessed so
many confidential areas without health
it's thought Snowden may have stolen 14
people's login credentials to maximize
his reach Pro Snowden sources say that
he used to sysadmin title to trick
people into handing them over anti
Snowden sources say that he may have
received help from Russian intelligence
back in the real world portress was
desperately trying to convince Greenwald
that her source was on the level that
March they tentatively agreed to meet
Snowden face to face yet the trio they
missed the first chance that very month
on March the 30th Snowden flew back to
the u.s. maintenance but rather than go
to meet the journalists II went to see
his father on April the 4th 2013 Loni
and Edward they had dinner Lonnie said
that his son seemed preoccupied that
something was weighing him down when
they finished eating
the two men hugged I love you dad said
Snowden I love you too son Lonnie
replied back in Hawaii that disconnect
between Snowden's private and public
lives it was growing at the same time he
and Mill's moved into a new house Glenn
Greenwald was receiving two thumb drives
with instructions on how to encrypt his
communications not the green world was
the only journalist Snowden was courting
Barton Gellman of the Washington Post
was also in contact with Snowden in May
of 2013 and was even given the first
Mitch cache of NSA files but Gelman
wanted too much time for fact-checking
angry at the delay Snowden simply cut
him off between his secret chats with
Greenwald Gelman and Poitras Snowden was
laying the groundwork for his escape he
told his employers that he was suffering
from epilepsy just like his mother and
he needed some time off on May the 17th
Mills left for a sailing vacation with
friends with remarkable understatement
Snowden told her that he might not be
around when she got back three days
later
twenty-nine-year-old traveled to
Honolulu Airport and got on a flight to
Hong Kong he had with him four laptops
and a stack of thumb drives carrying an
estimated 1.7 million top-secret
documents about a week later Greenwald
got a message river is newly installed
encrypted system asking him to come to
Hong Kong not unreasonably Greenwald
asked why in response Snowden sent him a
welcome package as Greenwald opened the
files
his eyes went wild here
in black-and-white was solid proof that
the NSA had knowingly lied to Congress
about the extent of its covert
surveillance programs and this was just
the taster the main course would be
waiting for him in Hong Kong provided
that he would come three days later on
June the 1st 2013 Greenwald was on a
plane headed for Asia along with him
were Laura Poitras and veteran Guardian
reporter who in MacAskill the story of
the century
have just begun now before we get into
their story of the century let me tell
you it that about - Lane - Lena one of
these sponsors who allow us to make this
longer form content now this video talks
a lot about data security but this isn't
just something that nations have to be
aware of you do as well - Lane is a
one-stop-shop digital identity
protection tool that includes a VPN for
all of your devices so you can use
public internet safely and anonymously
they also do something called dark web
monitoring which basically means they
monitor the underbelly of the web for
people selling your data and then alerts
you if this is happening further if a
service you have signed up for
Equifax or Sony for example suffers a
breach - Lane tell you right away and
they'll alert you to other services
which share that username and password
so you can change that information
before hackers get access to those other
sites Plus - Lane does what it's always
done it stores your passwords it keeps
your personal data secure it fills all
of those annoying boxes for payment info
and passwords all for you a lot of -
Lane is free but there are some premium
upgrades you can buy if you want to get
more from the service to see if those
arrived for you you could take a 30 day
free trial and after that get a 10%
discount code using our code biographic
s' @ - link aam /bi graphics link also
below and let's get back to the story of
the century shall we
[Music]
much later when the dust had settled
Glenn Greenwald would write that he was
expecting to meet a veteran of the
intelligence services in the hyper
crowded city he expected someone
middle-aged grizzled and maybe some gray
hair very much looking like a secret
operative in Snowden though got the
exact opposite prior to leaving the
reporters are arranged to meet Snowden
in the lobby of the mirror Hotel an
imposing glass edifice in trendy Kowloon
Snowden had supplied them with code
words and said that he would be carrying
a Rubik's Cube the first day Greenwald
and Poitras waited only for Snowden to
not show the second day they waited
again keeping their eyes peeled for the
heavyset ex-military man carrying a
Rubik's Cube when they saw skinny
delicate Edward Snowden Greenwald later
said that his heart sank
still they stuck to the script Greenwald
sauntered up to the young man and asked
what time does the restaurant open that
noon came the reply but don't go there
the food sucks for a moment the two
stood there awkwardly then Snowden
muttered follow me and add them to its
room right up until Snowden began
talking Greenwald was convinced that the
whole thing was just a waste of time but
as they settled into the anonymous room
and Snowden began to spin his tale the
doubts they melted away what was left
was a feeling of sheer terror as
portress filmed Snowden told Greenwald
how the NSA could hack any phone in the
world and turn it into a microphone that
spied on its owner
he explained that nearly every social
media platform had been compromised by
the US government and its allies in
Britain Israel and elsewhere were also
hoovering up metadata on every citizen
and this gave them an accurate picture
of your entire life your loves your
dreams your frustrations your desires
even the type of sleazy movies you like
to watch all of this was available for
them to access privacy it's just an
illusion
at some point Greenwald invited in
McCaskill up to meet Snowden as the most
experienced reporter there McCaskill
would be able to sniff out if Snowden
was faking it he even had a special code
to use with the Guardian officers if
Snowden was hoaxer hid text a single
sentence to the US editor the Guinness
is bad not long after a text arrived at
the papers officers saying the Guinness
is good Greenwald hands me
skills first storia went live at 7 p.m.
on June the 6th 2013 he telling how
phone company Verizon had allowed the
NSA to collect data on millions of
Americans it was an absolute bombshell
barely 24 hours later it was followed by
Bart Gilman's delayed Washington Post
story on the NSA's prism system in NSA
headquarters the stories triggered a
meltdown they knew they had a mole but
they didn't know who it was
On June the 8th the agency used digital
footprints do identify Snowden as the
likely leaker and this was the moments
when the young hackers normal life it
ended to this day the extent of
Snowden's theft remains unknown the NSA
estimates 1.7 million documents went
missing of which only 1% have been
released something the rest found their
way to the Kremlin others believe
Snowden wasn't lying when he said he
took no copies to Russia like so much in
this town of Lies and shadows the truth
to this it remains hidden but on that
day in 2013 the NSA they feared the
worst at 3 p.m. on June the 9th Snowden
consented to the Guardian uploading a
video in which he confessed to being the
source of the leaks he claimed it outed
himself to control the narrative to stop
the NSA spinning a false or counter
story former NSA analysts though they've
said it's because he's an egomaniac
before an hour was out the video was
playing all over the world by the time
morning dawns on June the 10th a wily
Twitter user had identified the mirror
hotel from its lamps as journalists
converged on the hotel's Snowden calmly
dressed and slipped out into the
sprawling concrete jungle of Hong Kong
it was a sweltering day the air thick
with humidity add Edward Snowden it was
now the most wanted man alive
[Music]
the ripples that slowly spread out from
Snowden's vanishing act
there were many affecting people half a
planet away in Hawaii Lindsey mills
panics and pulls her own disappearing
act vanishing to America's west coast in
Iceland's ARIMA that Snowden was headed
there caused mass Pro Snowden protests
on the streets and a diplomatic incident
with the u.s. in the Ecuadorian Embassy
in London Julian Assange left on the
phone and demanded WikiLeaks get a
representative to Hong Kong and co-op
the story this is how an eager young
Brit named Sarah Harrison wound up
flying to the city with a mission to
track down the NSA leaker in Hong Kong
itself a gang of human rights lawyers
led by Canadian Robert Tebow set up a
safehouse system giving Snowden places
to stay in the city slums as journalists
and intelligence operatives combed the
seedy streets and waded through pools of
neon Snowden disappeared into the homes
of Hong Kong's forgotten and neglected
today those that helped him all asylum
seekers are known as the snowden
refugees even without his main player
though the story it's still rumbled on
on during the 14 for the US Justice
Department charged the missing
contractor with espionage an arrest
warrant was sent to the Hong Kong
authorities
one week later Robert TiVo made contact
with Hong Kong officials asking if they
would extradite his client by now
WikiLeaks Sarah Harrison had
successfully found Snowden when Hong
Kong's people declined to answer she
suggested that he head for asylum in
Ecuador the net was closing in in an
interview with Glenn Greenwald CNN had
helpfully revealed that Snowden was
still in Hong Kong on June the 22nd US
authorities canceled his passport and
with that Snowden had to go on the run
the next day Snowden and Harrison
boarded a flight to Moscow supposedly
intending to catch a flight to Havana
and then another to Ecuador Hong Kong's
passport control failed to detain either
of them when asked why they would later
say that the US had filed an
international arrest warrant for Edward
James Snowden not Edward Joseph Snowden
that evening June the 23rd 2013
Snowden Harrison touched down at
Moscow's International Airport to a
media circus someone likely an official
in Hong Kong had leaked the airliners
destination to the press under
international pressure Russian officials
refused to let Snowden board his flight
to Havana at the time Vladimir Putin
claimed Snowden's arrival in Moscow was
an unwanted Christmas gift however The
Wall Street Journal has since claimed
that Snowden was in contact with
the Kremlin in the last desperate days
before his flight from Hong Kong
regardless it was here that Snowden's
time as James Bond finally entered stock
in the international transit lounge of
the airport for a month his entire life
was in limbo even as the Guardian and
Washington Post kept publishing stories
based on his material Snowden himself
was regulated to a bit part a strange
ghost hanging around an airport lounge
on the 1st of August 2013 over a month
after he touched down Edward Snowden was
allowed to leave the airport with
Harrison the whistleblower was granted
temporary refugee status in Russia and
he's been there ever since but don't
worry this video is not going to end
with Snowden slinking out of a Moscow
Airport one warm day in 2013 there's
still one more act to get through the
legacy of Edward Snowden is a story in
its own right not least in how different
countries treated the revelations in the
UK agents from GCHQ raided the Guardians
offices and snatched up their hard
drives
not long after Parliament passed new
laws actually expanding that agency's
powers in the u.s. Obama led the charge
personally criticizing Snowden but
nonetheless setting up an independent
panel examining US surveillance
practices in December of 2013 the panel
recommended that a bulk collection of
data be suspended as unconstitutional
today the NSA operates under close
congressional oversight so what else has
happened
well the Snowden revelations arguably
led to the EU's extremely strict GDP on
data protection laws just as they led to
Russia China and others passing data
sovereignty laws meaning any data
collected on their citizens must be
physically stored on their servers in
their territory as for Greenwald inque
well they wound up winning the 2014
Pulitzer Prize on the darker side US
intelligence agencies have said the
damage done by the leaks was irreparable
trust it was lost between nations and
terrorists were given intimate knowledge
of NSA operations as for the man behind
this chaos well it's been a mixed bag on
October the 9th 2013 Edward Snowden was
spotted in Moscow for the first time
since leaving the airport not long after
his father blond flew out to visit quite
what the two talked about their day
remains a mystery
in March of 2014 Snowden made his first
online speaking appearance at Texas's
South by Southwest festival today such
engagements are his main source of
income netting him an estimated two
hundred thousand dollars a year what the
life is all roses and honey for the man
trapped in Moscow in 2018 a despondent
snowden told reporters that russia was a
corrupt society and he no longer felt
safe there as for the United States
Washington still considers the
whistleblower a wanted man so at the
ends of all that excitement what can we
really say about Edward Snowden was he a
hero or was he a traitor the answer well
who really knows I can't really answer
the question despite we here online it's
likely that no one really knows the
answer except the Edward Snowden himself
the story of Edward Snowden it's not
over yet it could ends with an
unexpected presidential pardon a week
from now it could end in 60 years when
Snowden dies alone in an anonymous
Moscow apartment still a wanted man or
it could end in a billion other ways all
we know for sure is that the final
chapter in the life of Edward Snowden is
still to be written but its place in
history well that's already assured so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did give us a thumbs up below
do not forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this multiple times a
week so hit that subscribe button and
the bell if you want to say you know you
actually find out about these videos
also support us by supporting our
sponsor dashlane please find a link to
them below and as always thank you for
watching